I feel like for years I was fighting
that I had so many different parts of my
personality and really yearned for
having One Singular Focus but that's
just not who I am I just surrendered to
it instead and I'm much happier I'm a
multi-if in it but ultimately I am a
Storyteller and I like connecting with
people and I like telling stories in
various
[Music]
forms Paige elington got a shout out
already are you shorts are hysterical
she interviews Fascinating People on her
podcast and she's also writing a movie
hi my name is paig elkington I am a
podcaster actress writer comedic
personality on the internet among other
[Music]
things I grew up in Knoxville Tennessee
had absolutely no idea that I was going
to have any type of career in the
entertainment business I didn't know
anyone who was in the entertainment
business I moved to LA to work for a
entertainment agency had a normal
corporate job I started making comedy
videos on my Instagram and on Vine at
the time and other platforms that were
going on and built a following that way
I would say relatable is the consistent
theme with all of my content whether
it's podcasting Instagram or
writing all right
okay as someone who's childless and in
their 30s like parent is such an
abstraction to me and like no matter how
many times I hear people describe
Parenthood I don't think accurately
conveys it I have a podcast where I
interview people that I think have cool
jobs or are doing cool things in life my
content on the podcast is very open
vulnerable funny out there and I would
say that the content that I create for
Instagram and for Tik Tok and for
YouTube is normally very funny the aim
is to make people laugh but with my
writing projects I would say that is
where I move out of the comedy space my
recent projects have been a lot of like
dark comedy or drama or things that are
a little more
[Music]
depressing I also am the spokesperson
for underwear company called culprit
underwear and I've done a lot of really
fun videos with them and commercials
with them that have gone viral and I
would say that that's like where people
actually recognize me the most um will
you go out with
make we tried it once didn't work what
about me what about me no you
shop all stuff first shop at cprit
under.com also just the following I have
on Instagram I think just from being me
hate using this word but influencer
comedic personal hybrid the more you're
putting yourself out there of course the
more people are allowed to perceive you
or have an opinion about you that's just
like part of it I have been so lucky to
not have a lot of hate and Internet Hate
like I don't have a lot of people who
violently hate me yet um yet it's been
interesting figuring out how to monetize
my gifts my skills the the content I
make lucky for me I was able to kind of
find this Niche where I was using my
comedic gifts to sell products for
Brands so I've found this really amazing
position where I'm kind of the folks
person for companies selling their
products I think in the past everyone
was really into doing like traditional
marketing like commercials and now we're
seeing the rise of Instagram ads and and
Tik Tok ads and you know YouTube ads and
there's smaller Productions but I I have
a lot more creative control but I hope
that my biggest project is yet to come I
just finished a script that I'm really
happy about it's in development with a
company right now so I hope that these
next couple years we'll mainly be
focused on writing and making films and
television
shows as I look ahead I think there's
going to be a space for smaller projects
to really succeed which I'm thrilled
about I think people are more open to
original content from people that they
haven't seen before maybe it's like
their first time directing or writing I
think we'll see a lot of stars coming
from you know social media platforms it
makes it easier to break into an
industry that was once really tough and
the old model didn't seem to really be
working people couldn't take the same
creative risks that they are now please
continue I'm constantly toggling between
like I want to fully delete my Instagram
and also I need to be making content
every single day for Tik Tok and
Instagram buy them so they sell out so I
don't have to keep doing this
job I think there's going to be a return
to indie film making I think there's
going to be a space for smaller projects
to really succeed if you think about
what's happening with the strikes right
now the way things are going right now
is just not the way and I think that
people are going to start investing in
indie film making and smaller projects
in a way that maybe hasn't happened
[Music]
before